look who it is
what are the odds you and I'd end up at
the same summer camp relax
this it's that on you it's on our little
spider friend I've got some boys on the
outside who'd love to meet him you know
take a picture slice his throat put his
head in the dryer hey everybody its
charlie
meet your new spider-man villain Jake
Gyllenhaal so all the trades are
reporting that he's going to be joining
the spider-man homecoming sequel as
Mysterio now they're all quoting him as
Quentin Beck so you can kind of see that
they're slowly building their sinister
six this is the second main member of
the original sinister six that we're
getting in a big spider-man film so
we'll try to explain what's going on
with the timeline in Avengers four
careful for spoilers from infinity war
and if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's giveaway stuff
happening at the end of this - so right
now everybody knows
spider-man is seemingly dead but Amy
Pascal and Sony have quoted that the
spider-man homecoming sequel picks up
minutes after the end of Avengers 4 well
those movies will all take place in the
world that we are now creating for for
you know for Peter Parker what I think
that means is is they're gonna do the
same Civil War type tag where you have
that pre sequence where you sort of
address what happened during Civil War
then you get to the events of spider-man
homecoming they'll do the same thing
with Avengers 4 because it's such a big
event they'll have just killed half of
all people in the universe then brought
them back so they'll need some sort of
connective tissue to remind everyone ok
everybody's fine this is what's going on
but in the way that the original
spider-man homecoming movie dealt with
the vulture who debuted during amazing
spider-man number 2 we're gonna be
dealing with the Quentin Beck Mysterio
who also guess what debuted during
amazing spider-man number 2 he was
dressed up as an alien
disguise to mask the crimes that he was
committing so remember that scene where
spider-man is fighting those criminals
in the ATM booth that are dressed up
like The Avengers it was kind of like a
version of that they were all wearing
masks pretending to be aliens but
obviously because we're in the MCU you
have to like sort of change everything
based on the way they changed homecoming
from the original spider-man comics so
the beauty of the Quentin Beck Mysterio
character is that he is a tech based
villain in the comics he's a
special-effects wizard working in
Hollywood who then turns to crime
you talk about motivation there are all
kinds of subplots from later in the
spider-man comics like there are
hundreds and hundreds of spider-man's
stories from them to pick from way down
the road after his first big team-up
with the sinister six Quentin Beck gets
cancer because of the prolonged exposure
to all the chemicals that he uses to
weave his special effects that make it
look like he has magical powers so it
becomes this big ironic thing they might
try to add subplots like that to give
Jake Gyllenhaal's version of the
character some more motivation like the
vulture in spider-man homecoming which
is trying to feed his family and then
things went off the rails so like he
didn't start out trying to be a villain
the government damage control stuck it
to him Tony Stark took our jobs
so you identify with them a little bit
but then obviously things go completely
out of hand but they're still relatively
small time criminals that was the big
joke of the movie is that no no this is
way below the Avengers pay grade but the
thing is now though is that it does
sound like they're slowly moving to
sinister six territory because of that
post-credit scene you know I got some
friends that would love to meet him
slice him up real good
that was the Mac Gargan scorpion they
didn't say whether or not he would be
returning for the sequel but he is
supposedly in a version of this silver
and black script remember that silver
sable black cap movie that Sony is still
supposedly making we think it's gonna
happen
supposedly he's one of the main villains
of that script but there are a couple of
trays that are reporting that the
vulture will return but I don't think
that if he returns he'll be a really big
character it sounds like they're gonna
focus mostly on Jake Gyllenhaal because
he's a relatively big a-list actor
pretty big-name playing a pretty big
comic book villain but they might tease
a little bit of sinister six in the
background where the vulture has an
opportunity to help spider-man because
he did him the solid it was kind of what
that post credit scene was about -
because Mac Gargan is like we heard you
know who's spider-man is and he's like
you know what if I knew who he was
he'd be dead now so you could already
say his debt with spider-man has been
squared but I do see a scenario whereby
they turn him into more of an antihero
where he does find himself in a team-up
situation where he has a more real
opportunity to help
spider-man out in take down Jake
Gyllenhaal's character but don't be
surprised if Michael Keaton does come
back even if they do tease sinister six
and he's only in the movie for like five
minutes
I'm just not expecting a whole lot from
his character the funny thing about
Quentin Beck though is that in the
original sinister six team-up
he sends a bunch of robots after
spider-man I don't expect them to go
that far in this movie but remember we
have the tinkerer he has not been
arrested he's still out there
so the tinkerer could be collaborating
with Quentin Beck because Quentin Beck
makes a lot of elaborate special effects
based on technology the tinkerer is
someone who makes things so it just
makes sense that they would find each
other so even if the tinkerer is also
not a really big character in the sequel
I expect him to be reference because
their operation during homecoming was
pretty much where every low-level
criminal in the tri-state area got their
[ __ ] our tech from that they had
modified so think about them carrying
that forward to what Mysterio does like
really good at sleight of hand special
effects but imagine you throw [ __ ] our
e-tec into that but bringing it back
around to infinity war in Avengers for
finger-snap it just feels like from a
practical standpoint that the way that
they fix things and Avengers 4 involves
wiping everyone's memories of the
finger-snap because just think about
planet Earth think about the panic that
was caused during the shatori invasion
of New York think about the way that it
changed things for everyone on the
planet going forward we got to Civil War
there's now regulation people freaked
out just because of those big conflicts
that were relatively localized to
different areas like yep New York you
have sokovia what would it be like if
everyone on the planet remembered half
of them just disappearing into ash and
them mysteriously coming back they would
be so much panic financial markets would
crumble the only way in the easiest way
to fix that would just be to use the
power of the gauntlet really like the
mind gem in the reality gem in
combination with the power gem to just
fix everyone's memories so that they
don't remember but here's the thing you
know I think that most of the Avengers
that survived to phase four will
remember the events of infinity war
because there's always lots of questions
about like when you use the gauntlet to
change things like fan o's
APS's fingers how does he keep himself
from being erased randomly in the finger
snap because it's supposed to be random
like he didn't pick and choose who got
erased if you want to get really
technical about it you know he probably
used the gauntlet to selectively kill
half of all life not including himself
like there was probably little extra tag
on there that they just didn't explain
during the movie
so Ironman or someone else uses the
power of the Infinity gems to fix
everything by the end of Avengers 4 that
person can ensure that the guardians of
the Avengers that survived remember what
happened during infinity war bringing
you back around to the Spider Man sequel
there been a couple other details
they've talked about they're filming all
over the world as if spider-man is gonna
be traveling all over the world now
there is a subplot during spider-man's
fights with Mysterio where he goes
around robbing museums most of his
stories are localized to New York City
because this is really early era amazing
spider-man comic book so this is like a
long long time ago but obviously now in
the wake of Black Panther they want
spider-man to be a more international
hero so what they might do is just have
Mysterio conducting heists all over the
world in spider-man follows him around
but one of the other cool Mysterio
subplots before he joins the sinister
six is that he starts framing spider-man
for a bunch of different crimes in his
first really big appearance it was
amazing spider-man number 13 so you can
read that if you want Mysterio pretends
to be a hero by seemingly saying that
he's going to take down the criminal
spider-man he'd been going around
robbing all these places making it seem
like spider-man had been conducting all
the robberies so obviously spider-man
defeated him eventually but because he's
a special effects wizard they could
actually include that subplot in the
film to where Mysterio pretends to be
spider-man framing him for a bunch of
different crimes all over the earth talk
about meta storylines - there was
actually a time when Jake Gyllenhaal was
considered to take over the role of
spider-man Peter Parker from Tobey
Maguire if he wasn't going to continue
in his sequels way way back so think
about that plot where he pretends to be
spider-man in the comics framing him for
crimes imagine if they do the circle is
now complete and bring classic Jake
Gyllenhaal almost spider-man back around
through that that would be hilarious
and because the infinity war blue
ray is going on sale at the end of July
early August I'm gonna do the giveaway
for that so all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video so click here for all my
Deadpool Easter eggs and click here to
learn about the new eternals trilogy
that they're gonna be doing in phase 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]